more esteemed opponent in the world and
garry kasparov on your right Veselin
Topalov has proved too much or maybe we
should say gary is simply too rusty as
he's entered to the arena against one of
the top players in the world and he
hasn't been able to control the basic
mistakes he's just not fired on his
cylinders thus far some kind of
combination of the two years I would say
as it usually is the case but two games
left us play let's see if Gary can bring
back that golden form
efore be 693 were the first few moves in
Queen III I prefer this can we get away
with getting f4 in it yeah that's
certainly a much more ambitious idea and
I would prefer so but the problem is
with winning when they play c5 suddenly
the bishop c7 ideas I'm feeling I'd like
to see this I like just just for fun
yeah I know
of course Gary doesn't think this is fun
he wants to win he's lost the match it's
actually to somebody who's competitive
as Gary Kasparov we've seen him play
exhibition mats we know that this is
just as important to him
even though the match has already
decided Knight to g6 was vessel on his
choice and what do you think it's gonna
be yes he's gonna start with a four you
think he's gonna go with f3 is in
previous games that's tough I yeah
f4 f5 I think is the so f3 mm-hmm it's
tough it's a I'm not sure Jennifer I
just I also was about to make an
argument for Knight to d3 as well as
Bishop e2 but f3 was Gary's choice gonna
win bishop age 4 and then I'm ready to
play have five and f4 and suddenly I'm
black I'm feeling like I'm playing the
white pieces right sees this early
initiative Bishop h4 I think will be met
by Queen III stopping f5 you can't take
the pond because of the pin right 9h for
so after Bishop h4 I'd have to Bishop H
for Queen III I'd have to figure out a
way to yeah it's gonna be hard for me to
get into 55 was vessel UN's choice I
move that we've seen a lot in these with
the idea of maybe developing with Bishop
c7 right well here I'm all about D to d4
I would really like to get this move in
in order to get my pieces out very very
concrete so that you can't your Knight
to b3 1993 is a beautiful-looking move
but we don't want to play it now in step
you know I really liked I really like
playing d4 earlier is your choice I get
the feeling that I'm I'm guessing maybe
I'm wrong about this but I'm guessing
that the intuition and e5 was played in
the intuitive idea of improving the
worst piece in the opening he's going to
have to be modified along with also
getting some domination in the center of
the board something a foothold for white
because when you're doing this trying
just to improve your piece black seems
to get time to be able to be able to do
what he wants I don't see to e7 yes
great no oh I need a 7 yeah you gotta
trade off that really good night yes you
do oops
oops those were smothered mates
well d6 first was seven d6 so that the
King has a square so this is about
before with the Bishop a4 check coming
in I love it let's do before how do you
you can't if you I'm turning Bishop 84
check which is really kind of
devastating would probably provoke
before would probably from a ship c6
that awesome no like if you take on
before well it's not really mating
because you can always say b5 okay but
it's also a cool kind of demonstration
of some of the weak squares that exist
in 960 normally a seven is not as weak a
g7 is very weak in this construction
because it's only defended by the book
King it's d7 is the new a7 d7 is the new
love it I'm thinking 92 in order to
reinforce these two outposts the f5 as
well as the d5 outpost 92 looking to
play Knight to c3 followed by Knight to
d5 and Gary is all about outposts he's
looking at Knight to d5 as well as your
b4 move I do like this move b4 i think
it's i think it you want to time it when
your night is already on d5 though we
have the move g7 g 6 as Veselin is
looking to play queen g7 so he can
castle bishop c2 Knight to c6 Bishop C
to bishops it was worried it looks like
some kind of f5 break which seemed whoa
that would have been helpful for
possible anyway and now the knight is
headed to d4 and that's going to cause
bottleneck in the position this position
is looking very symmetrical and well
what do we do after Knight d5 nike5
played come on what does 95 do you're
thinking that blacks in our fight was 94
and he's done that he's done 94 oh ok
right now right now there's some serious
chess
action and this this is looking very
very blocked you're gonna need a big
well or that f4 is gonna have to come to
just fixed well let me play Bishop takes
d4 I'm gonna get rid of this Bishop
that's sitting on a that has been done I
like that exchange a lot actually and c5
takes d4 and I'm again I'm all about
your move d4 f4 instead f4 also looking
cool and 97 Knight f6 is still checkmate
yes but how would he have met before by
the way before would have been a variant
ok ok so 7 kind of tried to do both
through the F
6 squared otherwise take some e5 and
Knight f6 would have been really ugly I
was about to suggest that I was going to
trade on e5 and sacrifice on with Knight
takes d4 Queen g7 is an excellent move
not only dude developing weed are also
defending what gets great with me you
have to trying to reinforce this idea of
taking on e5 and maybe getting tonight
at 6 with a some penetration in the
endgame and 5 wasn't a good idea there
because of f6 was that at the point f 5
and 5 f6 I guess at 5 f6 is a good move
and done it castles
yes he's and he's ready with f6 against
any pawn push so slowly black is
unraveling and he's prepared to play 97
finally to trade off those nights
although I might get the feeling that
black wants play Bishop takes as well f5
on the board
that's right f5 has been played and
you're saying here you think the f6 is
gonna be playing Auto f7 f6b 5 instead
allowing the movie the move f6 at some
point Queen 86 he's on a different path
to challenge 97 was maybe awkward
walking into f6 type of ideas but Knight
b6 is a better way of challenging the d5
Knight so are we snoring f6 has a real
move that's the key Nev 6 looks looks
growers until 1886 1/2 points to play
Bishop a5 and suddenly the tables my
dude Bishop to d3 has been played they
ship d3 boy let's say I don't like
Gary's move Bishop d12 c2 I think that
the that Bishop would have a better life
on the d1 diagonal okay we are here by
the way the clock favors Gary for the
first time in a while way a little bit a
little but still was good the way he's
been playing when you finally just
exchange Bishop takes on d5 giving him
two options and Gary need
to just basically make a move right now
but he's looking to see what makes sense
CD 5 is what my old trainers video lee
Saltzman used to say is the the right
way to capture that every Russian
schoolboy knows capture towards the
center well it's also a lot of other
things going on our Bishop Bishop
becomes bad with that
kallu big-time move by vessel and he
just captured on f5 exposing his King
Quan takes f5 quickly played by No 83
not 5 years of age for wet night night
g3 Bishop h4 mist Knight Bishop h4 sorry
I missed that I got myself all excited
about a knight coming to f5 f6 is real
because when you put the Queen on h6 now
your king is still quite airy and
leaning back in the chair like yeah got
it
and nodding his head as well wow that
kind of confidence that a part of
landing on f6 doesn't do any damage to a
g4 and Gary's not buying it
Gary is saying wait a minute this bond
is huge well he's trying to play g5
after which you can't play Queen g5
because there's a work to you one in the
position that's a pawn sac though he's
just giving away his pawn to just keep
the attack going Knight takes d5 g5 the
Queen would have to move to H h3 no h3
Bishop f5 your queen would have to move
to h5 but then I got no I don't have 93
whoa
this is double-edged yeah g4 intuitive
by Gary forcing T'Pol off into a long
thing as he's wondering about this
possibility of the move g5 yes I like
whites and he's like Queen h3 at once
which doesn't seem to change the g5
concept well we can now move our Bishop
to e4 so we don't even have to give up
this guy but Bishop e3 met by 97 Bishop
f5 is even stronger
I played Bishop f5 is even stronger he's
just attacking now he's gonna leave g5
and he's going for it it doesn't matter
if you pick up one he's taking the pawn
you said you can have that one play
Queen h5 just greedily keeping all the
wood hanging on e5 14 h5 your life okay
does Gary you have a put away move he's
not played Bishop b4 he's trying to play
fast guys one minute and 20 seconds for
Darien that Veselin well under a minute
and congrats to sam Shanklin for winning
a game and snot Mina bleeding it what
it's been it's been a long time coming
let's put it that way
MBL has been in beast mode today Jen
just played turn tremendous chess a very
very deserving victory by Maxine Gary
with a huge lead on the clock to Paulo's
flag is precarious right now his time
looks like but the problem is for vessel
and he has no easy obvious moves and
he's played Knight f4 returning the pawn
is that 19 seconds it looks like he has
left
it sure does 19 seconds and Gary about
to regain the pond and Knight takes T
not except for ef4 I'm expecting Queen
Age Queen afore remember he's gonna need
his anything at some point
yeah but the king by the way why can
still cast yes why does itah
why canst is there isn't there rook
hanging on b8 so there is a rook hanging
on b8 but Bishop f3 and can I cast I'm
sorry
rook the rook is not Hank the rook
wasn't happy it was hanging but the rook
was hanging on b1 oh I see what you're
saying yes okay like please please move
my rook because there was that rook g1
that important and that's okay my rook
is hanging too so let me let me prepare
Bishop c7 many moves for Gary right now
they're all looking looks like good
dominant in this position h4 looks good
played h5 taking on nothing wrong with
it but instead b7 attacking the Queen
Gary reaching first Queen let's just
play Queen to g4
as Esalen
Zess to stay in the game just played the
move h6 boy that pawn on e4 d fight
looks scrumptious I mean that looks free
yeah well it's not only that but we
could play Bishop b4 trapping the Queen
well hey rook e1 preparing bishop d5
Bishop b4 Gary will smack himself in the
head if he doesn't win this one the
position is so dominant Bishop a5 just a
flicker of a move of no real threats
there's a matching for the takes and
dare him to take Kenny can't capture yet
on d2 but now he can 5 and a check and a
exchanged sacrifice as he found a way to
win the Queen garry kasparov
back in business witty